si versailles m'était conté ça n'est ni
du cinéma ni de la littérature mais une
décision historique le château de
versailles va retrouver son unité et
avec 25000 nouveaux mètres carrés s'est
occupée par le parlement qui a accepté
de restituer ces locaux se fit jouve
emmanuel gagner je pense que c'est très
bien qu'on ait le droit de visiter notre
j'attends et oui c'est une petite
révolution
nos députés nos sénateurs au nom sans
fin à la vie de château
car depuis la troisième république les
élus occupaient les ailes de ce joyau de
la monarchie soit un tiers de sa
superficie
vingt-cinq mille mètres carrés au total
que jean louis debré a décidé de
restituer à l'établissement public de
versailles montrer
le bureau le bureau du président de
l'assemblée nationale qui sert pas à
grand chose et qui va être rendu au
public n'aura plus votre bureau non non
pourquoi vous n'avez pas l'utilité parce
que je sers à rien il faut toujours
supprimés ce qui ne sert à rien seul
l'hémicycle du congrès restera à la
disposition du parlement
mais les présidents les questeurs et les
hauts fonctionnaires des assemblées
devront renoncer à leur logement de
fonction souvent sans objet puisque ils
en ont déjà un à paris pour les
responsables du château au contraire ces
lieux récupérées ont déjà leurs
fonctions ce qu'on peut dire c'est
qu'ils vont être mis vraiment à
disposition du public pour améliorer
l'accueil pour améliorer la formation la
billetterie mais aussi pour très vite
mieux accueillir les scolaires qui
actuellement ne dispose que d'une tente
alors qu'ils sont plus de 300 milles de
venir chaque année à versailles bien sûr
la libération de versailles ne s'est pas
fait sans résistance le sénat lui a
traîné les pieds mais a fini par voter
cette semaine la proposition de loi le
château de versailles sera bientôt
rendue au peuple de france et aux
visiteurs du monde entier